So I liken it to, um, seeing a parent with a toddler.
Like if you're at a restaurant and the toddler is freaking out and screaming,
and there are the parents that give a toddler what he wants and that's like
terrible and white America. When we,
when they see these radicalized black people, cause it's not all black people,
but they get the attention, right? These radicalized black people screaming,
Welly about something, they just give them what they want. No matter what it is,
defund the police. Okay. We'll just start talking about,
to find the police because you've made that ridiculous,
absurd demand that has never been made ever. Um, and so I,
it's hard not to think that this is actually the fault of white guilt, right?
This is, this is white guilt gone too far.
You guys are like overdosing on white guilt right now.
All right.
Let's talk about the other thing enough about COVID, uh, racism, Candace.
It's everywhere. There's more of it to go around than ever before.
It's a miracle that they even let you use Skype right now as a black woman.
I mean, what do we do about this situation?
I mean, I think it is really time.
The challenge now is to just dear white people,
what the hell have you been thinking, allowing this to go on
this far? You know what I mean at this tail in between the legs, Hey look,
my ancestors,
I can at least say we were dragged with chains and whipped and beaten into
submission white people today. I don't even know what this is. This is crazy.
I mean, I've never seen such people, um, that are just so willing, uh,
to, to fight for their own oppression, right? To say, Oh,
I shouldn't deserve it. I should stepped down from my job.
I shouldn't be in this room. I shouldn't be able to say anything.
I should be silent for a day. And it is just such a,
such an openly hostile okay. Society. Um,
in terms of treating white people poorly. And,
but white people had dug the grapes. So it's very bizarre to me. And, you know,
I liken it to, um, seeing a parent with a toddler,
like if you're at a restaurant and the toddler freaking out and screaming,
and there are the parents that give the toddler what he wants and that's like
terrible and white America. When we,
when they see these radicalized black people, cause it's not all black people,
but they get the attention, right? These radicalized black people screaming,
Welly about something, they just give them what they want, no matter what it is,
defund the police. Okay. We'll just start talking about,
to find the police because you've made that ridiculous,
absurd demand that has never been made ever. Um, and so I,
it's hard not to think that this is actually the fault of white guilt, right?
This is, this is white guilt gone too far.
You guys are like overdosing on white guilt right now. Um.
Hey, not me lady. I'm not guilty for anything. I haven't done me personally,
but you know.
And so, um, I always just ask,
please stop giving the toddlers in the black community, what they want.
And similarly, I won't give your, you know, freakish little Antifa, white thugs,
what they want, you know? And, um,
and there just needs to be more people having a bit of a spine, I would say,
in the white community.
Did you sense that this thing was coming sort of like what we were
always against when we would do college events together and it would be this odd
sort of Antifa thing, but we didn't know exactly what it was.
And it was a little bit before BLM had like fully exposed itself to be,
but all of this. And as I said to you in our other interview,
and as we've always done it, every event we've ever done together,
we take questions from people who disagree with us first,
but are you shocked how quickly in the last six months,
this thing like molded together and BLM and
Antifa and the Marxists and the Twitter,
like the whole thing just morphed into one really evil monster,
really freaking fast, all sort of under the COVID thing.
Like it all happened at the same time.
Right? Um, I wasn't shocked. I mean, I had been warning about this for years.
I kept saying during an election cycle,
you're going to see race issues drummed up now how violent they'd gotten. Yes.
That surprised me. Um, and uh,
also I would say I've been shocked by the permission they'd been given and the
excuses in the past as they've been given, uh, by politicians.
I never saw that coming. I, I would think a store gets robbed looted, uh,
torn down, burned, and you know, no matter whether you're left or right,
you know, you would stand up and say, this is wrong.
The inability for politicians to now acknowledge what's right. And what's wrong.
That has shocked me. Uh, we, we put a real low point when, um,
people are saying, this is okay when politicians don't have the spine and say,
you know what, I'm actually not okay.
It's been in the police and we need to isolate this incident in compromised
incident and not say that every police officer is wrong. Um, and so I,
I am shocked at how much the left hates America, um,
and how much the left hates people that do the right thing,
because that's really, what's come down to it with you do the right thing.
If you earn accolades in life, if you climb the ladder in life, they hate you.
And they're saying, there's not a place for you anymore.
There's something fundamentally wrong with free market capitalism,
with everything that American and Western ideals in Western principles were
built upon. So that part shocked me, but not this narrative.
I was seeing it everywhere I went and I knew that they were organized.
They were well-funded and that they were going to come ready to fight. Yeah.
Do you, how do you see any chance of getting out of this thing? I mean,
as you said, you expect Trump to win.
I think you would think he's going to win big.
I think he's probably going to win big too. And it's like,
no matter if Biden wins, if Trump wins, if Biden wins big, if Trump wins big,
it's sort of like, I don't see a way we get out of this either way.
I could see some version maybe where if Trump wins by truly a
landslide, like, uh,
like a Reagan re-election situation that maybe finally the
last few decent Democrats get the kids out of the adult table,
like the kids that they've let taken over that sort of what you were saying
before, maybe they do it themselves. Um,
but that doesn't seem very probable to me.
Do you see any way we get out of this thing?
Well, the only way we get out of it is if people,
and I think we are actually going to,
starting to get out of it now in a weird way,
because people are starting to see socialism manifest, right?
Marxist principles manifest.
So looking around their neighborhoods and they're seeing, you know, uh,
stores being looted stores, being robbed violence, happening,
police getting shot, individual, uh,
cities that are gone up in crime by something like 267%, right.
In New York city and in Chicago. Um,
and they're seeing that the suburbs are now being threatened.
They're gonna come to the suburbs.
They're telling people in the suburbs to leave their house. You saw,
I'm sure the video clip of maybe you didn't because you were away, but, uh,
throughout DC, they were going up to white people at restaurants and
saying, put your fist up and say, you know,
black power or else you get screamed at.
So these people are now seeing you've supported this,
and now you've seen what it's become.
And I think that once those people understand now not once they see that
manifest they'll change their perspective and they'll they'll vote differently.
Right. And then of course, once the Democrats,
if the Democrats lose a ton of seats, it no longer serves them to,
to be funding these Marxism who's no longer serves.
And to stand behind the violent criminals, it no longer serves them, uh,
to pretend that these criminals were righteous and you'll see a dramatic change
in society. And I think that it will secure as it did in England.
And I'm hoping to see what we saw in England where after Brexit, it just, every,
every vote went to the Tory party. Um,
I think that we will see the same thing in America and we'll save this country
for a lot of time to come because people will not forget this.
Yeah. I, I, since you're kind of right. You know,
I hate when they say the gay community, the black community,
that community thing, I hate that. But, you know,
I saw this poll just since I've been back that at one point, I guess,
post the convention,
24% of black people were thinking about voting for Trump. Historically,
we're looking at like 4%, you know,
I tweeted something like a year ago that I thought Trump was going to get 30% of
the black vote. And I know that might be a little crazy, but I still,
I think that the mask has been pulled off and I think something crazy
is going to happen. I really do. Are you with me on that.
A hundred percent? You know, I've been saying this forever and I was laughed at,
in the beginning, right. When I first said black said,
and I said that my vision had always been 20 points by 2020.
I knew it was possible because the left can no longer hide from itself.
And I was so happy when AOC hit the map, uh, because she was just saying it,
you know what I mean? The old school Democrats with it hiding what they wanted.
And then AOC kind of took over their party and said, no, this is what we want.
And they capitulated to what she was saying. And so they couldn't lie anymore.
Right? They couldn't lie about the fact that they were supporting these Marxist
principles and the destruction of family black lives matter on the website,
destruct the nuclear family. You know, this is wrong, this is backwards. So,
and I've just seen so many people that people,
you least suspect that I contacted me privately celebrities,
and you would just go, this person posted a black square.
I was persons of Marxists and just going,
I've had an awakening and I would like to have a private conversation with you
offline. Um, and I think that that's me,
it's just made me feel just happy. Like all of this hasn't been for,
not all the beatings that I've taken and it hasn't been for not.
Looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics instead of
nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.